so that means you really messed up this
has gone completely off the train rail
seems the more I cut the worse it gets
it's been about a month and a half since
my last haircut and as you can see I'm
looking how the economy's feeling rough
around the edges the curls are fresh and
alive usually I like to keep them a
little more tame than this my name is
Nick Romero I'm a master barber but
cutting hair for almost 19 years now
I want a barbershop in San Diego
California I used to cut my own hair and
I would just go and not really care just
as long as I had a buzz cut and then
month and a half ago Nick the barber
came into my life and had me looking
fresh bro
two days after and we established I was
gonna grow the top of my hair out the
country got shut down I don't know how
I'm feeling about the beard I'm gonna
line it up we're gonna edge it up along
with my taper up here I'm gonna taper it
down this way but I might get rid of it
I don't know we'll see with everything
that we have going on right now I want
to help you guys create the best haircut
you can do at home let's go
quarantine cuts I've got my clipper I
don't got the like super-close butter
ones so my plan is to just use my
regular razor to do the zero and then
fade up I put on this crunchy crusty
little tie-dye shirt that I got from
school and we're going to pray let's
have a moment actually before we even
start this list it looks like the side
you have maybe like a number number four
so we're gonna go with the five first
the clip so you're gonna get is gonna
come with a set of eight to one although
you're gonna grab the five your head
goes like this right and the top of your
head is like a head shape so your head
with like this is a 90 degrees we're
humans right I remember him saying
something about a five so I grabbed this
low five and I'm gonna put it on the
thing
oh my gosh oh here we go
I'm gonna do a five and a half oh it
cuts 500 cuts
my hands cut off oh my gosh
is this my Britney belt this is a
session as I'm gonna have to vacuum
after this how you do it
let me see the side all right so you got
maybe like a three three and a half so
what I would do if I were you from this
part of the ear right here I don't know
what this is called
oh you're online you're home from here
up you do ask in faith that's hitting
zero you're gonna do a zero right here
from there you're gonna go straight
across to your ear
no no you're going up you're going up
you're going up you're going up go
straight down towards your ear
I'm calling you a matter this swing
can't swing heating the zero I had a
tough time understanding but it looks
like it's just gonna go straight into
this
bulb on my ear pretty dramatic not
looking too faded so I'm completely
neglecting about difficult how you get
the back you guys need a mirror you're
gonna need to look in the back of your
head which is gonna be the hardest thing
possible because you guys have never
done this before when you're cutting
hair in the back of your head it's
difficult because what you're looking in
the mirror and you're going this way in
the mirror is going this way so you have
to understand that you're not cutting
this way you're cutting over here
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
this looks atrocious what I recommend
you doing do a straight line going up
cousin your neck is 3d your neck is
round we're gonna go up this way a
little bit slightly slightly know if
you're not up there you're below your
ear
our taper doesn't go past your ear you
want to make sure that it doesn't go
past the mid your mix middle of your ear
okay well I don't even know what's on it
this has gone completely off the train
rails it just it goes down so hard bro
look at that I'm so itchy right now
there's so much hair on yeah could I
possibly get my girl to help me with the
back yeah you can yeah that's cheating
Irish no okay no you already know wait
hold up you know this gives you yourself
okay I'm gonna have my actual barber
help me with the back man whoa help help
fine I can't do the taper that we had
initially planned but that's how hard
because I was supposed to come at it
like I was my plan was to just come at
it like this and then fix the back but
like it got so screwed up in the back I
think I might just make it a fading
straight around my bed the back is rough
oh Jesus I think at this point the bags
absolutely unsalvageable seems the more
I cut the worse it gets so I might as
well just show him what I've done so
that I can just shut up by tomorrow this
is the face of somebody who regrets
everything we've ever done I was gonna
try and get myself an edge up and stuff
too but that's very ambitious and that
is that's just not happening today nope
[Music]
let's see all right okay okay that's a
typical issue right there a lot of
people don't know how to get rid of that
bottom line let me see the other side
you look like you belong in the vampire
blade movie perfect it doesn't look bad
I can definitely even talk you through
it over the phone and you can either
look better than what it is with the
same notes that I gave you I would have
done probably the five and then have to
crown the four and a half before but
three and a half three working down once
you did that zero line and you do that
one
now you're fading the one into the three
I don't want to incriminate myself worse
but I'm gonna correct you I didn't have
to fade I had the taper oh you had the
taper and ain't you Oaks
so that means you really messed up you
see simple Irish oh it went off the hay
was a simple haircut oh I can't wait to
see angel
okay the dramatic reveal drumroll please
okay okay I can't see from the front go
ahead let me see give me 360 there you
go
okay you went and gave yourself a high
and tight look at that
it's almost faded in the back now with
yours you wanted to keep the top right
yeah it's harder harder got to keep the
top this was a rough experience mostly
because my hair was a lot longer than I
thought it was I'll tell you what if you
would have kept longer hair on top and
did this it would have taken a longer
time for your hair to grow back and get
back to where you at least wanted to
feel normal you know I feel like this
was a good first attempt won't by you
know definitely could use some help with
like blending and stuff like that like
as a professional barber what would you
rate each other I would give I renewed
it'd mess it up where you can fix it
back about a five five five and a half
and then angel I could still fix it it
looks like you didn't gave me so much of
a fade up to the line it looks like it's
all one number right there so I'm gonna
give you a four but you guys did good
you guys did great I think we I think
you guys can do a better job on each
other about that I extremely fat
actually I think it would have been way
easier if I did not have to reach the
back of my head you guys did great I
really I bet you did awesome
[Laughter]
[Music]